hello everyone
welcome to my session uh at ndc sydney
good afternoon to uh audience from
australia and good day from if you are
watching it from elsewhere around the
world
today
i'm going to talk about how we can build
enterprise microservices using autoload
and
azure
apparently the oslo here has got a set
of azure eyes
my name is patrick zhao i'm currently
working as a senior software architect
at ssw melbourne office
i'm a full stack engineer and speaker
here's my twitter handle
if you want to be a little bit more
formal
there's a link to my linkedin
and at ssw each consultant has his own
profile page you can easily find me by
googling patrick at ssw
in my spare time i like to follow some
great open source projects over github
and also contribute to some of them
my recent interest being a
conversational
ai chatbot
that can serve as a virtual receptionist
so
if an organization wants to set up a
virtual receptionist that can help its
guests to find its employees with
certain skill sets and availability
and you can feel free to download and
spin it up in your own environment
come have a look
um i also have a personal blog i see
it's a great place for me to uh
every now and then retrospectively uh
summarize the lessons i've learned from
my recent projects
the my understanding for some new
technology
so
since i graduated from
melbourne uni i have been in the art
industry for over seven years during
which i have successfully led
architected and delivered a great
number of
solutions for my clients across
different industries
with a special focus in fintech industry
and my expertise and interest
in includes big data machine learning ai
and most importantly azure
i've been recently helping i client to
migrate i joined
applications from a
classic but a bit old school monolith
architecture to modern microservice
architecture and that's why today i'm
happy to share some of the
knowledge and lessons and challenges
that i learned and or got from that
project
so
here's tonight's agenda first of all
when we talk about our monolith
does it mean it's bad or it's a mess
or when we talk about uh microservice
although it's more modern and more up to
light doesn't mean that it's perfect
let's do some uh comparison so that we
have in some overview
overarching understanding of monolith
versus microservice
then
i'll i'll spend some more time to
uh have a deep dive into the micro
services and with a
a focus on what kind of um
pattern that we should advocate when we
are trying to implement microservice and
what are the key elements a microservice
solution is composed of
and then ob now will narrow down and be
more specific to azure what type of
services we can leverage to build our
microservice architecture
and
as
the way that i usually usually delivered
a
presentation i prepared the demo which
is a quick plc of the
simplified version of microservices
architecture that we can
use
that we can build on azure
okay so
monolith so what is the monolith doesn't
mean that we have a bunch of lego bricks
which
which are completely unorganized and a
mess
no it's not
monolith
is a unified architecture
where
i see it as a very clean and
clear architecture so what it means is
that you have your user interface that
you the user uh interact with and all
the way down it follows a transaction
scripts pattern that the
up layer for instance here the user
interface interacts with the
downstream layer the business logic and
business logic interacts with your data
access layer and data access layer
runs quad operations with the data store
and it returns the data all the way up
so the modernist architecture is quite
actually quite clean
so it's not a bad thing it's not
able to use moderate architecture but it
has its own problem so next let's look
at what are the pros and cons a monolith
architecture has
so the biggest advantage when we use
modernist architecture is that it's
self-contained
it can have a lot of features
functionalities within a within the box
but once it's done it's self-contained
once we've done the devops once we've
done the uh pipeline to release it once
we've configured the hosting environment
it's done it's all self-contained so we
only need to look after one suite of
um
environments or
artifacts
so that way
we can
narrow down our eyesight to
look after a particular thing
although it can be very complex inside
and since
it's self-confined so it's easy to test
and debug and mind you here by testing
and debugging i mean
treats the monolith application as a
black box
so this is more from like the
integration test perspective if we don't
need to break it down and dive very deep
into the
into the solution itself but we rather
um throw some inputs to it and assert on
the output then it's easier to test
and there's less overhead in cross
module communication usually so if you
take doughnuts as the programming
language usually the cross module
communication is done via dll if you
build your application in node.js it's
uh you are the cross module
communication is done by referencing npm
package
so
there is no network traffic no grpc call
no rest no graph api call nothing like
that so
the overhead is is minimum
with with all that
although
over time when your business logic grows
more complex uh more or less
architecture has problem but
to begin with if you are not sure about
the potential scope that your
application is going to grow in three
years say
it's easier for you to just start with a
a modernist architecture for your
greenfield project
so we've looked at the um all the
advantages now let's look at some of
these advantages or the potential
problems so
so i would ask the risk on this first
one just to remind you that um when we
say that a monolith
architecture can be easily coupled but
only if it's done wrong so what i mean
is that even with modernist architecture
if we
follow clean architecture and we
incorporate it with some good patterns
such as cqrs command query uh
responsibility segregation or event
sourcing um
these are our
our expand on those architecture later
because those architecture can also be
used in microservices architecture
um
if we
incorporate
these
clean architecture and
good cloud patterns into our modernist
application the modernist would become a
modular monolith so it's this
a cost can be flipped to props if we've
done it properly but it's very hard
because of some other issues that are so
shortly
um the second one is to it's hard to
update individual feature again this
downside can be flipped to our upside if
we've done it properly we've have a
modular approach
then each individual feature can be
updated
individually um
but this hard block with monoliths
application being it has a massive
copies in a single repository
what this means is that since
our model is is self-contained so we
have to have everything in your in your
repository including your database
migration scripts your application code
your conf
most of your configurations
um what is resulting is that when a
developer tries to pick up some product
background item they need to have at
least a minimum understanding of at a
holistic level
so without an understanding of the
overall application you won't be able to
even start working
uh the other hard roadblock is the
scaling the scaling is also holistic you
either have to scale the entire
application because itself contains
deployed in one single housing
environment
but it will increase unnecessary cost
i'll also expand on that
in a bit
so
with all the downsides modernist
application has
some
organizations
are thinking about moving from monoliths
to microservice
and this happens when
there is a brand legacy system
which could be smoothly running
or getting some patches but and some
minor you know fixes over the last two
decades
but when we are trying to
migrate this type of application for
whatever reason maybe some technology is
um is end of its general uh
is gi supports
we need to migrate then when we try to
migrate this
big giant system
it's very difficult and risky to migrate
them all in one go
so what we tend to do is we call a
strangler feed pattern that we want to
migrate the application bits by bits
and
this way
there are less risks and it's easier to
manage the overall project we can cut it
to
smaller milestones
and the the deliverable of each
milestone are
easier to manage and easier to sculpt
secondly
we've mentioned that in the previous
slide that the scalability for a
monolith application could be a problem
because you have to
scale at a holistic level so
if you if only a certain part of the
system need to be scaled up and done in
or out um microservice is the way to go
and lastly
the microservices tend to increase your
development team's productivity because
by embracing microsoft architecture your
engineers uh tend to
tend to only require smaller
amounts of knowledge from the business
domains
because they only look after a certain
part of the system so um they don't need
to
have a you know overarching
understanding of the entire business so
they can spend more time in delivering
so here's a good analogy
um that i found on
google
so for instance we have a
a lego pyramid
and if something goes wrong for instance
we want to replace this this green brick
so if it's a monolith's pyramid what we
have to do is that we have to put down
at least the top three layers and in
order to replace this small brick
whereas if
uh virus violent reconstruction
once we've migrated to a modern
microservices architecture if we're
trying to replace a
a small
break if it's been corrupted or whatever
reason we need to replace it we only
need to
put down this
small module and reassemble it once we
fix this small brick
so as we can see
the
uh cost of managing microservices like
patching or
bug fixes
can be reduced if we've done
microservices properly
so
now
we've had an overview of modernist
versus uh
microservice then let's move on to a
more in-depth uh discussion of microsoft
let's start with the key components
first of all usually we want um to have
an api guidewire that serves as a single
point of entry
um
and that api gateway can sit in front of
your subsequent microservices and serve
as either proxy or handle more complex
scenarios
and we want to support different types
of front-end it could be web desktop
mobile
and we also want to
be able to deploy our subsequent
services in a flexible way
and each microservice needs to have its
own data store here the keyword is data
store
rather than database so multiple
microservices can potentially share the
same database but
if they share the same dollars they need
to have they need to own its
its own schema
what it means is that we should prevent
cross-service data access and this is
the key
principle and the pattern that we should
follow when we are building microservice
and we want so from the coding pattern
perspective we want to advocate the
event driven pattern
and personally i like to
integrate my my microsoft especially
whatever sitting behind the api gateway
to be protected by v-net so that way we
can um
has we can have less worries about the
um security um and compliance practices
and we want to leverage messaging system
because each database sorry each
microservice has its own data store but
sometimes we want to interact with
other
other data store or external data then
usually we need some messaging system
i'll explain all these components in
details in a bit
so here's a great example that microsoft
has posted on their document repository
it's an e-commerce site and they use
this to illustrate the microservice
architecture
and they've been actively updating it
for instance um in like
a year or two ago when i uh so when i
saw and referenced this um example they
advocate um oswald but now they used
invoice instead so that means that as
technology involves evolves the
microsoft has been um looking after
their documents um
examples actively as well so it's a
great resource so as we can see
we have an api gateway which has
different variations we have an api
gateway that serves as a facade to your
apis or we can have a back-end for
front-end if you want support different
type of front-end applications
um
in this example uh the hosting
environment that they host the
applications as docker containers um but
there are other deployment options which
we'll touch on in a bit um the most
important um
insight we can get on this example is
that each micro service has its own data
store the dollar store can be a secret
database or can even be a radius cache
if we want to
uh interact between services we do that
via a messaging system on azure we have
android service bus or you can use your
rapid mq on it
okay
so let's move on
so
i just mentioned that there are
different deployment options rather than
docker so let's have a look so first of
all we can leverage
past services on public cloud providers
on azure data a lot of options
or we can choose to have containerized
applications uh on azure these other
container instances
and recently azure has rolled out
other container apps which
i personally didn't have much knowledge
about because it's new
uh but i like to explore
because they advertise this as a
service
containerized environment and it has a
smooth integration with dapper
dynamic application runtime and
kita so it's great i like to explore on
that as well
or
we can always use kubernetes if we want
to manage the cluster ourselves and we
have the expertise and experience in
managing that i'll measure this iks and
this great deployment option
so
uh we've looked enough on the tangent
side and on the development team's
perspective
um
if we start embracing microservice
architecture
it's not just about a software or
solution architecture but also about a
methodology and also a development team
management so we can onboard our new
developer in a fast pace and more
effectively
and because we can onboard the
developers um quickly so developers
become pluggable you can join a
microservice team and
do some work and finish off and join
another thing if there's need
so we can adapt to business requirement
change quickly as well so there's a nice
trend here
so a monolith um application because
it's so simple to start with so the
development speed could be very uh quick
uh at the beginning but as time
goes on over time the productivity is
going to drop
whereas in comparison the microservices
to begin with you have a lot of
cross-cutting concerns to worry about
and you have a lot of things to set up
so
at the beginning when you're setting up
the foundation it could be slow but um
over time the productivity is going to
grow because you don't need to
have a a
overarching understanding of everything
of the entire solution but you can
rather just focus on a small piece
okay so
from development to
release we have a devops
exercise
in
advocating microservice we can adopt the
real agile we can adapt to the changes
and have a have a faster iteration
and
the most important thing i like to
highlight is that
compared to the traditional modernist
application the concepts of deployment
and release should be separated so what
that means is that
we want to have a progressive release
strategy in which we can
um
use dark launch
or we can toggle features on and off
so what that means is that
for instance we have a feature and
that's handled by a
a single micro service it's easier for
us to turn it on and off
so we can release
these features to the markets
without a formal notification to the
user so we can collect some
use telemetry
and
get the feedback to improve our
application this can be done with
smaller lens if we
do models properly but with
microservices is much
easier so we've looked
at
all the goods and benefits and all the
upside of microservices let's look at
some potential challenges and the traps
the biggest
challenge is that
in microservice architecture
we can potentially get into a um
circumstance get into a a place that we
call micro monoliths what this means is
that
um if we've done microservices properly
we don't have a cross service reference
uh each service has its own data store
that will offer event driven pattern but
for instance there is a method that's
sitting in a module that need to be
referenced by
five different services
and and if we make some change on that
module all the five different services
need to uh will be impacted which means
that we have to wrong test we run a lot
of tests to make sure that our change on
that so it doesn't break in that module
doesn't break those five services if we
have a lot of modules like that
we get into a
situation that's
although we our services does not
reference each other but they all
reference the same thing so this is a
micro monolith
we should avoid that
and the way to avoid that is that to try
to package your module
and publish them
as as programming packages so in dotnet
we have new get in those players there's
npm package
and by properly packaging them and
shipping them
to the new gets we can have a proper
versioning so the services can choose to
upgrade if they want to
reference some
updates in the package also the other
services can stay with the older version
of the package if they don't want to
change so this way we can
make sure the impact is minimal if we
might change in the shared library
the other thing is from the data
perspective
um we don't want to we don't want uh
cross
uh service uh data referencing but
sometimes we have to
for instance we want to i in in a
typical e-commerce
application when we are checking out we
want to reference a customer's
information such as the address with the
transactions which the payments have
settled and the transactions are posted
so that way the payment
service or the order service need to
reference the the customer service
and
there are two ways
we can
achieve it the first one is to reference
external service what this means is that
a
your customer your checkout service can
emit an event or can call your customer
service directory but regardless of
which way we by following the
this approach we create a default
dependency between the primary service
and the independent service
and if your
external service goes down
you need to work out a while to mitigate
the the problem and what we do we either
retry or we
we we've been held up
as an alternative solution we can
duplicate some of the data
in
the microservices
data store
so as we know storage is is very trip
dislikes so
duplicating data
would incur an additional storage is not
a big issue however
because we're duplicating data we need
to be careful about the consistency
level of the data for instance if our
customer service is going to
provide the the referencing data for a
like user and we need to synchronize
that data across to your checkout
service
then we need to guarantee that when the
user is actually checking out we get the
the latest in the correct the light is
you know address the home address of the
customer that we're checking out
so
the the data synchronization process
need to uh bear in mind the data it
synchronizes need to have a good
consistency level that's acceptable by
the primary service
of course eventually the data is going
to come through but the data might be
still at that time
so this consideration that we need to
take into account
and
the and that's um can at a higher level
can be summarized as a reliability for
individual services because there could
be potentially be uh dependencies
between the different services if we
are not doing this correctly there could
be some issue that when a service goes
down it affects other parts of the
system
and the last one is the the most
difficult one that i i personally don't
even have a good solution for it is the
domain boundary so what that means is
that when we are
cutting different um
pieces of your business into different
problem domains so that each program
domain by design should have a
microservice to look after
if we are not
setting the boundary between the problem
domains properly what it would
potentially end up is that we can have
some microservice that acts as monoliths
which handles a lot whilst other
services handles a little
this is what we should avoid and from my
understanding the the real way to
there's no quick way to tackle this but
it all depends on your knowledge and
experience with the business domain
so
next let's look at individual uh parts
of a micro service architecture first of
all is api gateway
it's a single entry point
and
api gateway is nothing but a bunch of
middlewares
so that the uh cross-cutting concern of
a uh let's take http request an example
the cross-cutting concern of an http
pipeline can be obstructed out put to
its own layer that's it in front of your
um
micro services so microservices can
be uh can be
doing its own thing rather than worrying
about
you know your cookie affinity your uh
jwt token validation so and so forth
so
uh there are several tasks and api
gateway should perform the first one is
the simplest
scenario where a api gateway is just a
proxy it proxy the upstream incoming
traffic and route them to the subsequent
service
sometimes
it is more complex that you need to fan
out
when the apec advice emits some browser
message multiple services need to react
um and thirdly there's an even more
complex scenario where the api might
need to orchestrate all aggregates
when the front-end asks for the data
that's spread
across multiple services um your api
gateway need to fetch data and
orchestrate them
before it gives response to front
end and as we showed on the microsoft uh
microsoft example uh there is a back-end
for front-end
requirement for you for some of the api
gateways
so
let's look at our slot
so oslots is a great library that can
help us to build a api gateway quickly
it's a bunch of middlewares that's been
executed in a specific order so you can
see that oslot has a a
a big middleware in your entire solution
at solution level rather than your
dotnet web api or mvc level
and also those status to support
websocket which
it didn't use to support
so it's great
so
there are other options for api
apart from our slot oscillator is not
the only choice
for instance there's envoy so michael's
microsoft's example
started to use invoice
so it's a great alternative
and there are past offerings
on cloud providers let's take android as
an example
we can have we can use api management or
application gateway uh they are
different but i'm not gonna spend too
much time in comparing these options um
there's just one thing i like to
highlight is that when your api gateway
grows to a certain
complexity or you want to monetize it
it's the at that moment you should start
thinking about
using a past service rather than manage
it yourself
and and then and of course we can do uh
we can build up
api gateway in your kubernetes cluster
um for instance we can have
we can leverage nginx as your ingress
controller
and
i'd like to
integrate my microservice architecture
with v-net
so that we can use it to protect the
subsequent microservices
we only need to expose the api gateway
to the public
so this is why we can ensure that the
traffic uh between the microservices are
on
the backbone network that's offered by
the
cloud provider or
android for instance
instead of going um via the public
internet so this is why the
compliances and security can be
guaranteed
next let's talk about cross service
communication
the first pattern i like to highlight is
the saga pattern
it has two variations the first one is
the choreography what this means is that
let's take e-commerce as an example you
have you might have an order service
then when a certain event happens for
instance your order has been created
the other service is going to emit some
events and
some other service for in this case your
customer service may need to react to
the event that's emitted by the other
saga
and once it's sorted out
its
own business logic and uh changed the
sites of a transaction for instance from
the credits reserved
to
credits
exceeded or accredited credit limit
exceeded or the payment sorted
whatever event
uh once it's done its own operation it's
gonna meet another event so
other success can react on it
so this way the um
the
events are trained up and they've been
flying through different uh micro
services uh smoothly
there's an alternative to this
choreography pattern that is called
orchestration pattern that you have a
single price that's
act as an orchestrator that's when
the
events
need to be emitted
it's sent through a message broker
and when the other saga reacts on it you
get the message back and then you file
off another event from your orchestrator
so
either of these pattern works
but they are all event driven pattern
that which is
good for micro services architecture
so as i mentioned um we want to have
event sourcing when the states often act
when the states of something changed
so within the cycle pattern when a
particular transaction state has been
changed we want to be able to trace the
state's change and sometimes if we want
to rewind or reply so the event sourcing
pattern is a great choice for that for
that requirement
and
by uh in implementing all the soccer
pattern or usb panel we need some pops
up messaging service
and at last i'd like to mention but i
also uh want to remind everyone that we
need to be careful with cajon so for
instance if uh your external dependence
dependence service uh is going is going
down then you need to have some type of
question to make sure that you still can
get that data
but you need to be careful that
um
you don't get the scale data so we need
to introduce something called a circuit
breaker pattern
not the real circuit breaker but it
works in a similar way that uh whenever
there's
some abnormal
currents going through your circuits we
need to um open it so whenever there's
an abnormal events like the external
service goes down you want to make sure
that the service does not uh for does
not constantly ping and constantly
getting narrow but it will stop pinning
it and when the external setting goes
back we want to re-establish the
connection but only allow a certain
attempts or free trials
and we want to make sure that the states
are remembered properly so there needs
to be a slight machine to handle that
so
we need to be careful when we want to
when we want to use kitchen
and
so we've gone through the elements and
the pattern that we can use to build
microservice let's see what are the
services available azure can help us
uh first of all it's um we now unnatural
uh and keyboard
um we can um
store our secrets and the credentials uh
on keyboard that multiple services can
reference using a managed identity
so that's why uh we don't need to store
uh store the uh you know secrets across
different microservices
and what are the messages you can use to
implement the pops up
pattern and uh sorry the event sourcing
pattern
we have under service parts which
supports uh queue or
topic subscription model
and there's a there's a simplified uh
version of uh qr
on azure storage accounts
and there's also event hub
and event grid so there are a lot of
options
uh if you want to implement event
sourcing pattern um you can you should
have a look on this managed service
rather than
building the messaging system yourself
so here's a simplified um architecture
diagram um that's
i think it's it's easy when we build a
poc so as we can see
we have ipad here if the api gateway
supports web socket then um we don't
need this uh signalr whereas if our api
doesn't support web socket um azure has
a great managed service called signal
service that can help us to
manage our broadcasting service
so
uh i i like to place arena to protect
our microservices so the
communications uh within the v-net are
guaranteed to be secure and on azure sli
and we have our service bus
which
we can use as our pops up pattern
and as we can see each service has its
own data store it can be either cosmos
nosql or sql or cache or data like
whatever data store
and uh as a cross cutting uh cons is
concerned we can use um azure keyboard
to store our keys and secrets we can use
application such monitor our
applications we can use manage
identities
and
we can support different types of
finance and whether it's desktop that
you've done with different technologies
like electron or so it's a web format
now
so
uh we've done enough discussion um let's
get on to a demo so
in my demo i'd like to show you how i
use oslo to build an api gateway and it
communicates offloads traffic to
subsequent service
um
we start with adding the oslo package
and uh loading the configuration files
uh similar to how we load um our app
settings we can load uh different uh
loads the uh configuration files for
different environments
and then we need to do some
configuration in our startup.cs class
we register service and then we use the
service
there's nothing special
compared to other libraries
now
sometimes we want to use swagger so it's
easier for us to
play with our apis the way we add the
oslo swagger is by
bringing some
additional packages
and we add swagger for our slot and then
we also add the ui
next
if you want to add some authentication
schema for instance
jwt or cookie schema we can do so
by adding our schema uh in our api
gateway the same one as where the
osboard is hosted
and here's an example of an auto.json
configuration
as we can see
there's an upstream uh pattern that we
define so what it does is that whenever
it gets some
request from a
upstream pattern it will be mapped to a
downstream pattern to our downstream
service
apparently is that local
um i'll show you the configuration file
in a bit
but it's going to route the traffic to
downstream service and if there's any
authentication schema
we need to register it here
by
referencing the provider key
and also note support a lot of features
one of the the greatest features i like
is the header transform what it means is
that it can extract out a certain
information in your authentication token
for instance in jw token
we can extract other claims and then
transform it to headers to the
subsequent
service
so that your subsequent service can
reference the
header directory rather than passing and
validating the jwt token again
and if if you want to use swagger to
interact with subsequent service uh what
we have to do is to add a
a
this uh swagger swagger gen
definition in the subsequent services
so that's on the striker ui we're able
to call subsequent services
all right so next
let's get to the code
so first of all uh let me quickly show
you the um
the coding structure
so in the uh demo that i've prepared
we have an infrastructure folder as well
as the source code so i prepared the
ipad gateway and two subsequent services
so first of all let me show you the
infrastructure i have a bunch of bicep
files i'm pretty sure that you know what
bicep is from williams awesome talk
which happened on i think the other
check
just now
so i'm not going to uh expand too much
in explain what bicep is and how things
are booted up but
there's a nice feature i like about
bicep is that we have a visualizer on vs
code
and as we can see that we have let me
zoom in a bit we have multiple services
we have api gateway we have web app web
service one web service two which i host
them on app service plan which sit here
the linux app service plan server forms
and uh
yeah we can move this to make it easier
for us to read
um what they do is that they all
reference the sign up inside or
reference the same keywords so that um
we don't need to store the um any
security any sorry any uh credentials
across different uh
micro services
that's nice and cool and uh different
service cases on data store uh you don't
see that structure that clear here
because they reference the keywords and
to have access to the database
um
and i'll also show you how we can place
v-net uh i i'm i don't have v-net in
this uh bicep files because for the sake
of simplicity but i'll show you in our
android portal in a bit
so
let's go over to the code first of all
let's have a quick look on how
we scaffold the um api gateway it's it's
nothing different from a normal web api
project
as i showed before
get bigger as i showed before uh we can
load the autoloads file and a different
environment um if you look at the osmo
uh file
which we can run it locally it has a
uh it's a json file and it has an
object called routes and another one is
the swagger which we use to configure
swagger and also a global configuration
so
we can have different
upstream patterns mapping to different
downstream patterns over different
protocol
and certainly different ports and i i i
wouldn't demo the devops process but in
your devops process you need to somehow
do some json file transformation or you
can generate these production or slots
yourself
programmatically so for instance on
azure
the services all use port id so we need
to have port id here and then the
downstream service can be different urls
or your own dns
then managed by your dns provider or
azure
dns zone or dns global
now
as we can as we saw before we have swag
the swagger key that maps to the swagger
definition for subsequent service
and also the
authentication schema that we want these
gateway to transform
and also we need to substitute the base
url to be where your
api gateway sits
so this is the api gateway and i've also
prepared two subsequent services
so we have service one which does
nothing but just returns on data
showing that we it's actually written
data from a subsequent service
and uh prepared a login endpoint um
usually we want to wrap this to a
service but i just added controller for
the sake of simplicity
um
we can generate some jwd token and we
want that token to be validated by api
gateway rather than subsequent services
as you can see i haven't had any jw
token schema here apart from the swagger
definition which help us to use swagger
um
the on the other service that i also
prepared is that
we can try the header transformation
we expect to see the uh
client that we transformed by uh api
gateway rather than we providing it on
the api call
so
let me just
go
back
a step
so on service one what i've prepared is
sorry this one in the login process
we've added a client called the special
client just for testing purpose
and we want to see that these current
can be extracted out by
our api gateway and
attach it to the subsequent call to
service b
so that service b can
recognize it
okay
so enough um
enough
talk about the code bytes let's look at
the demo in action
so what i have is uh i have a gateway to
making sure that i'm on the ipad gateway
since we've configured swagger well we
can see that from api gateway's
perspective
we can
see the definition for service i and
also service b so just do a quick test
make sure that it works
so it says hello from service to
controller
um
i use ib and one two
you know interchangeably
and um
if we call
service one then we can see that it says
hello
now
um if we are trying to
access the endpoint that requires um
authentication
we defined in our oslo
file
what we potentially get is
401 unauthorized
this is the sign with the endpoint on
service b
remember that we uh want to see the
header that's been transformed here
so but for now we can't access it we get
okay let's get back to service i and
let's login
so let's put in some username it's like
patrick i haven't validated it so it's a
proper email but
let me just put in something
all right
something random now it generates a jw
token and let's quickly observe what
this straightwater can look like
so as we can see that's it contains the
name id and
the email well this is not an email i
didn't validate it sorry uh but
what we should uh
highlight on is this special client we
want to see this being
passed from the uh by being extracted
from the client that passed to api
gateway but also
been recognized by subsequent service
all right so let's go back
and grab a copy of it
so the cool thing about
swagger for ocelot is that you can
authorize it here you only need to
authorize it once and all the subsequent
services can leverage it so the first
thing let's test this endpoint that
requires authentication
when we hit execute remember we used to
get 401 but now we get 200
and now let's
switch to service b and here we let's
try the see if we can get a header so if
we click execute we see we get the
header out so we'll uh
review our code a bit just make sure
that we understand how it works
service 2 with us
simply just get
the header and return this in the uh in
the 200 response so now
what let's test if we try to pass it
with different header
will it get this header or the header is
transformed
if we click execute we see
it's not taking the header that will
pass to it but it transforms from the uh
api gateway so this way your api
giveaway is the actual entry point
and it could ignite the traffic and
attach the information you need to
attach to subsequent services
this is great
um
so um i've deployed it on azure if we
jump onto azure
what we can see
is let me
return a step back uh we have a bunch of
maybe we need to make a bit smaller we
have a bunch of services uh with
provision on azure
um
and
there's nothing special um
apart from the v-neck configuration so
as i mentioned before we want to have a
v-net to protect our service
so what that means is that we can access
the endpoint api gateway but not the
services themselves
so
let me quickly show you what i mean
if we click on one of the microservice
and we click on the url
we can see it because i haven't put the
vena access policy in price but if we go
to another
service that i remember i have put in
the asset policy already in place
we'll get 403 and the reason why we
would get 403 is that we have the
network uh networking configuration in
place
uh by that what i mean is
if we scroll down and move on to the
networking session
it was me
not working there we go it's over here
we can see that
we have an access restrictions on
what it access restriction is is that it
only allows the traffic
uh that's been
that's been sent to us within the v-net
and it denied all the other traffic
so how come the
then how come the api gateway can
offload traffic to it it's because we've
configured it to do so by adding the api
gateway to the v-net
and that's down in the networking
session over here
so as we can see we have a v-net
integration on for the api gateway so
what this means is that the
outbound traffic that's been routed from
the api gateway is going to uh to go
through the backbone
network on azure uh under this v-net and
subnet
so
whenever you impose an asset policy on
the subsequent market services um only
the traffic that you configure to allow
will be allowed um all the other traffic
from the um other you know public uh
public um
uh
requests will be denied
so
um
just as a quick uh proof if we uh try if
we take the
access policy off
from the service that we had the access
policy on what's going to happen
let's see
i can't find the networking again all
right so here this one
so if we
take this off
remove
so now we don't have any deny policy so
by default it allows all the traffic
so
after that if you try to access um
service one again
we'll see that well able to access
service one
from its own url
so
by leveraging v-net it's easier for us
to protect our microservices
and
offload the security and compliance is
concerned on azure si so that is that is
great
we can have less concern so that we can
have a more uh have a better
productivity on delivering the business
value in the mining application
okay with that uh i've demoed um how we
use um autoload to build an api gateway
and deploy api gateway as um app service
on android
let's go back to my presentation
and see a quick
summary
today
um
first of all uh we've compared monoliths
and the microservices
on the overview level and we understood
that monolith
is not completely wrong while
microservice has its own challenge
challenges although
i believe that down the track when the
business
has become more and more complex in the
world
uh you know in the modern world um
microservices tend to be the uh
architecture of preference for most big
organizations
and we also had a deep dive into
different key elements of a microservice
and the
cloud patterns that we want to advocate
when implementing microservice
we also
spent a lot of time looking at the
services azure offers to help us
implement those uh clean architecture
and those good cloud patterns
and i will also see a demo um of how i
build a quick plc of
using ocelot lot as api gateway and
you know the the other subsequent
services in
microservices architecture
so with all that that's the end of my
presentation there are references um
um i have uploaded the
code that i showed you to my personal um
github account
i'll be i'll be keep updating it to add
more stuff to it so hopefully we can use
it as a good template to start with
micro service architecture
and i also reference to this
microsoft.io as a great resource for
different cloud patterns
all right with all that thank you very
much
um
still have five minutes to go so if
there are any questions you're welcome
to drop down or if you want to discuss
offline um you know my um maybe let me
just move on to this slide
you're welcome to post them on the
social media links